And how,
how people are attached to that.
You know,
that they,
they,
they immediately think that this is something to mock and make fun of.
You know?
I mean,
it was almost universal.
So many people were doing stories on that guy bagging groceries.
Yeah.
It's the age we live in,
man.
People want to see people break.
If anybody's doing anything,
there's a chance they're just waiting.
People are so mad.
Look,
if,
if Megan Kelly,
if we didn't know what her contract was,
right?
If it was just some,
in fact,
let's say we did know,
and let's say she was getting paid barely what we would ever gas,
right?
Let's say she's getting paid,
I don't know,
$100,000 a year at her new job at NBC,
she probably still had the job.
She prepped,
right?
I mean it's the whole crazy part is that we all know she got paid $68 million
for three years for what?
Right.
That's the whole take.
So it's like,
you know what Ghana people are watching,
like what'd she just say about Halloween costume?
That's it.
We got it.
We got her.
Yeah.
Did you ever hear it play it Megan Kelly?
Shit.
What do you guys have?
Like the apology or the original?
No,
the apology was hilarious.
This woman
said that some woman from Australia said that it seems like a hostage video.
The only thing that is missing is her holding up a newspaper with a date on it.
I retweeted all I,
it's soda.
And then somebody else said,
well,
what if you,
there's one of the,
one of the things about it that's so strange is how insincere it seems like
forced like,
oh,
it's from a forester.
It's her apology.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Apology seen the forest.
Yeah.
No,
I haven't seen that yet.
But the boots,
forget the apology.
Let's play the actual videos.
Actually I remember,
if I remember correctly,
it's two comments.
She makes one of them,
they come back.
Oh,
the second comment I think was the real issue.
What was the first comment I,
I gotta get,
I'm don't,
I remember,
I don't remember.
So there was a controversy on the real housewives of New York with Luanne and
she dresses Diana Ross and she made her skin looked darker than it really is and
people said that that was racist and I don't know.
I thought like who doesn't love Diana Ross?
She wants to look like Diana Ross for one day.
I don't know how that got racist on Halloween
peered to be.
I'll see.
That's the first one
is it?
But it's weird when you watch it now.
Like you know,
this is her demise.
I like you're watching the stumble when she trips off the rock and falls off the
cliff.
This is the stumble,
like I don't get it.
How is that racist to want to be Diana Ross and then play it again?
Yeah,
Halloween like okay,
I could,
I was a kid that was okay as long as you were addressing that.
There's like a character
and that.
So some guys commentary from Wall Street Journal.
That was a wrap for their and be my favorite one of hers that she ever said.
No.
My favorite one of hers,
if we were good.
Yeah.
My favorite,
one of hers she ever said was,
uh,
there were,
there were doing this thing on Fox News about Santa Claus and someone had
something about Santa Claus being black.
They did something about Santa Claus being black and she just went,
ah,
well Santa Claus is definitely white.
And she was like,
I think she said it at kids like kids.
Santa Claus is definitely right.
Or it's kids.
Santa Claus is real and he's definitely white.
Like,
I forget what the exact terminology was,
but she basically said Santa Claus is definitely why like Santa Claus is in
fucking real.
Okay.
It's like saying Spiderman is definitely white.
She didn't get fired from Fox for saying that.
She probably got a raise for saying that.
Right.
They licked her toe is a whole different thing at Fox.
Well,
it was then they don't want her to know.
Yeah,
she wanted to go back.
No,
no,
we're good.
Yeah.
They won't him to take her back.
The thing is you can't go from being an ice princess and the conservative right
wing channel to being like Oprah.
What she's trying to be like Oprah.
I don't,
I,
I'll never really get what MBC was thinking there.
They were thinking it's a paper.
He was like,
those people are just going to come over.
Yeah,
that's exactly what they thought.
They thought she has a giant fan base,
but she had a fan base for sure.
Some came over,
but she,
a lot of her fan weight of base was because she was the beautiful conservative
woman who was a very tough,
very articulate,
very smart,
you know,
and they liked that she was an ice princess and she would shut people down if
they're incorrect and she wouldn't let people talk over her.
She was powerful.
Kind of frightening in a hot way.
Yeah.
Fox News has a bunch of those chicks just waiting,
waiting in the Helms delight that closet x Mokena when the dude opens it up and
sees all these robots with different skin and faces.
And
there was so many of them just teleprompters ready to roll.
Big,
big letters that they can read.
It clearly will tell you what you like.
Yeah.
They're making a movie.
And these three are the,
uh,
the anchors.
Yeah.
Fox News or Robbie,
Nicole Kidman,
and uh,
and meg Shirley's there on,
yeah.
I wouldn't mind being on the other end of that.
A porta potty.
How dare you see,
you could get fired for that.
Imagine if you were on a show and you've said that that would be the end.
Like that this is a beautiful thing about podcasts.
Yeah.
Nobody gives a fuck that you said that it has zero consequences,
but like,
let's,
let's pretend that you were on the tonight show and you were a guest and you're
like,
I like being in the end of that porter potty.
People be like,
oh,
did he really,
really,
that woman was just tried to go to the restroom.
You think that's funny?